(intense music)
(water splashing)
- [Narrator] This can be
scary, and rightfully so.
Sharks have patrolled the waters
for over 400 million years.
And while they are powerful creatures,
our stories have given them the reputation
of being vengeful killers.
Hollywood says so.
- You're gonna need a bigger boat.
- [Narrator] So does the media.
- [Reporter] A life or death struggle
with one of the ocean's
most dangerous predators.
- [Narrator] But are sharks
really the human hunters?
- [Announcer] Terror of all
men who enter the ocean.
- [Narrator] Or the hunted?
- [Reporter] Well, it's going to be
a beautiful sunny day today.
You might want to do some
of those outdoor activities.
(upbeat surf music)
- I think the reason
that sharks are feared
by the general public is
pretty self-explanatory.
(whistle tweeting)
They frickin' bite people sometimes.
- [Narrator] This is Jess Cramp,
Nat Geo explorer and
founder of Sharks Pacific.
She also lives near a lot of roosters,
so you might hear this.
(rooster crowing)
But back to the shark bites.
- It's unfortunate that it
happens, but it does happen,
so trying to avoid that fact,
I feel like is a bit futile at this stage.
- [Narrator] These rare
bites typically stem
from curiosity or mistaken identity,
yet how we feel about
sharks versus the data,
that's a different story.
Like a really different story.
We think all sharks look like this,
and do this.
But actually.
- Sharks are an incredibly
diverse group of fish.
Some sharks live most of their lives
in a really small radius,
just within a few coral heads,
and others will swim around the planet.
They range from whale sharks,
which are the largest shark species,
and they get to be about 40 feet long,
down to the dwarf lantern shark,
which is about eight inches.
- [Narrator] That's cool,
but when did they become the bad guys?
Let's ask one of the people
behind the International Shark
Attack File, George Burgess.
- [George] As long as
humans entered the sea
or floated upon it,
the inevitable conflict
between humans and sharks was present.
- [Narrator] From the Greeks,
Romans, and Spanish explorers,
tales were written about
battles with sharks,
but fast forward to when
leisure time became a thing,
and Americans started going to beaches.
The shark attacks from
those ancient tales,
they weren't really happening.
- [George] It became obvious
that shark attack
certainly wasn't as common
as people were saying it was.
So the pendulum had swung
from one side to the other.
- [Narrator] And this
millionaire was so convinced
shark attacks weren't a thing,
he offered a $500 reward
to anyone who could prove
him wrong, wild dude.
As in, would jump into the water
with a real shark at parties wild, yeah.
Also, many scientists at the time agreed.
Until this happened.
- [George] When 1916 came around,
and there was a series of attacks
that occurred on the New Jersey coastline,
suddenly the real world slapped
everybody across the face.
(slapping)
- [Narrator] Starting on July 1st
and spanning two weeks' time,
the coastline of New Jersey
witnessed five shark attacks
resulting in four deaths.
People were spooked.
Locals even attempted to fight back
by throwing dynamite into
the water, seriously.
(upbeat jazzy music)
- [George] Because the
New Jersey coastline
was a popular vacation
place for the elite,
including the president,
there was immediate concern
and action that we had
to get this taken care of
because I got a vacation already
planned later this summer.
- [Narrator] The White House
agreed to give federal aid
to "drive away all the
ferocious man-eating sharks
which have been making prey of bathers."
Eventually they put the blame
on an eight-foot juvenile great white,
but by then it was front page news.
The damage was done.
While 1916 played its role
on sharks' reputation,
it was a fictional story
that really did a number.
Yup. You guessed it.
- [George] The book and the movie "Jaws,"
as in any good cinema or any good book,
if you can get the reader,
the viewer fully immersed,
then you've done your job.
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] Consider
the audience immersed.
The novel by Peter Benchley
spent 44 weeks as a bestseller,
and the movie became the largest
grossing film at the time.
It essentially created
the summer blockbuster.
- [George] People believed
every last bit of that was fact,
even though it took great
liberties with facts,
some knowingly, and some
just because we know more now
than what we knew then.
- [Narrator] One such belief
was that sharks are
vengeful human hunters,
which in turn led to a surge
in humans hunting them.
- [George] Shortly after
the movie came out,
there was a great influx in
shark fishing tournaments
up and down the East coast
of the United States.
As a result, shark
population began to decline.
- [Narrator] Today, scientists estimate
a staggering 100 million
sharks are killed every year
around the world.
And to make matters worse,
sharks are specially vulnerable
because they take longer to mature
and typically produce their
young at a slower rate.
- So sharks are in trouble.
While habitat destruction,
pollution, and climate change
are definitely problems for sharks,
our biggest impact is through fisheries.
- [Narrator] Overfishing of
sharks is predominantly led
by the demand for their
fins, meat, and liver oil,
and the lack of management
to ensure shark fisheries are sustainable.
- The way that we can make
the most impact for sharks
is actually through working
with fishing agencies,
with fishermen, also spatial protections
on important critical habitat for them
to try to reduce mortality and
create a few more safe havens
where they can actually
hang out and repopulate.
(soft marimba music)
- [Narrator] The common
narrative of sharks
will likely continue to be on
rare attacks, but in reality,
the species are in need.
Even Peter Benchley came to this truth
as he later focused his
efforts on shark conservation.
- [Peter] If there's one
thing I know for dead certain,
it's that I couldn't
possibly write "Jaws" today.
I could not turn this
beautiful beast into a villain.
- Shark conservation is
not a one size fits all.
It's a multipronged problem,
but they are fixable,
and that's the one thing that
I think is really important
for people to know
is that these are problems
that while we may have created
them, they are fixable.